more now on the conviction of Israeli
soldier Ella Azaria who shot dead a
Palestinian attacker as he lay wounded
and immobilized on the ground well
joining us now is Jerusalem Post legal
correspondent yo nabob Jana good morning
to you thank you for speaking to us here
on Sky News so what do you make of this
verdict was it a fair conviction in your
opinion yeah it was definitely a fair
conviction I mean any trial can go
either way going back in terms of the
background this is from March 24th to
Palestinians attack and it's really
check point in the very rocky city of
hedron one of them abdel-fattah Sharif
stabs one of the soldiers both of them
are shot one of them is killed Sharif is
wounded about 10 minutes later an army
medic on a lot of other people come on
the scene the army medics name is
alura's aria he's the one who this is
all about and at some point on film very
very slowly he moves over to Sharif and
takes a shot in his head basically bows
his head out very very gruesome the
video goes viral much of the
international community can bend this
what's different about this than some
other cases which people say sometimes
Israeli prosecutions whitewash is Israel
actually invites him and not just for
negligent homicide which has happened
before but for manslaughter and that is
what makes this case so unique it's been
almost 12 years it's an Israeli soldier
was indicted for manslaughter in a
situation like this so his side said
look this was an operational situation
he thought maybe Sharif was going to
reach for a knife Sharif was still
moving a little bit even if not much or
maybe hit a suspicious coat on and there
was concealed explosives on other which
is rare but has happened and is
something that people are soldiers are
worried about in this current knife
Intifada wave of violence between Israel
the Palestinians going back October 2015
so but overall the judges said look we
don't think there was actually a
concrete danger the knife when you look
at all the video footage and the
testimony wasn't close enough to 10 it
wasn't really moving and this concealed
explosive idea
it was something you came up with
afterwards one of his friends known only
as TM under gag order even testified
when he asked him afterwards what
happened he said I killed him basically
cuz he stabbed an Israeli soldier my
friend so that made it clear that this
was a vengeance act not an act of
self-defense overall I think there was
some evidence for both sides but I think
you think it was a fair ruling but it
has really divided opinion hasn't it and
Benjamin Netanyahu's called for him to
be pardoned do you think that's likely
to be happen so it has been very very
divisive on a level of a fight over
these really Army's values how should
these really are me address terrorist
situations or raise situations where you
might have somebody doing some about the
violence but is there really a danger in
this knife Intifada I was talking about
in these really domestica political
arena you have the former defense
minister against the current defense
minister the former defense minister
became former partially because he was
too critical amela rosario whereas Prime
Minister Benjamin Netanyahu has been
sort of middle of the road well I don't
endorse what you did but I have sympathy
for you and then there's also the
International Criminal Court is looking
very closely at this case because
they're evaluating whether Israel system
of prosecuting its own is valid is he
going to get a part in even Netanyahu
and a lot of officials are calling for
that I think at the end of the day he
won't because of who's president at the
time president Rubin rippln has been
critical of people who are criticizing
the courts in the IDF legal system so I
think he's going to probably support the
decision a pardon would be seen as
undermining the decision but there are
other people who would if they were
present at the time might have rented
apartment rivlin I think that a what
sort of impact do you think this verdict
will have on Israeli soldiers and their
conduct moving forward now that is a hot
debate there are going to be people
critics of this decision we're going to
say they're going to be Israeli soldiers
who are going to get hurt and we're
going to even die because they're gonna
hesitate to shoot if they're not sure in
a situation about how dangerous somebody
is and on the other hand you have people
are supporting decision we're going to
say this is what the
Israeli army about is about yes it is
about defending its citizens but it's
also the defending international law and
even an attack or even a Palestinian
attacker who stabbed in Israeli soldier
has rights if they are that at that
moment what we call you know neutralized
they can't actually be a threat you
can't kill them it's almost like
somebody waving a white flag so that's
what the question is going to be the
next time is a grave situation somebody
attacking with a knife not right on top
of somebody but from a distance how are
soldiers going to handle that or we're
only gonna have to wait and find out all
right you're a nabob from The Jerusalem
Post thank you for speaking to us hair
on sky knees